irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
cot malabar enchevêtrement de lagune de
canaux de petites villes par un caprice
de la nature pour le plaisir des yeux
présentement des autres
c'est aussi l'hymne des noms
belligérants se sont par extraordinaire
des hommes et ils sont presque amphibie
il ya fort longtemps que se sont
réfugiées ici pour refuser se mettre à
l'abri des entreprises guerrières
leur destin pêcher le coquillage
la loi ne faire surface que le panier
plein
leurs ambitions justifiées justiciables
nourrir leur famille
on chamboule un peu mais ça rapporte
tout de même
voici rajaona rajaona est séduisant mais
mauvais pêcheurs ce qui le loue à deux
destins le premier rentré chez lui
presque toujours bredouille et le second
y être malgré tout fort bien accueillie
par sa charmante et jeune épouse
laquelle vous voyez là temps
et aujourd'hui il ne rentrera pas
directement une croisera un filet de
pêche qui gère plutôt à nourrir les
oiseaux que les hommes vous avez voix
il prendra cette immense à l'est
car il ya un but
et il croisera en même temps que vous et
moi un cortège nuptial
l'inde étant le pays des passions
cachées ne vous sautera pas aux yeux que
les deux époux sont ivres de bonheur
adjani moult
un peu le rouge un peu de bleu un peu de
blanc un peu de vert tout dans un papier
et il reprendra son petit canot ils sont
retournera chez lui voyez-vous les époux
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure
c'est air accablé cacher un grand
bonheur
ce tambour bas
parce qu'on veut annoncer la fête de ce
soir
le son qu'il fait d'entendre ça ira très
très loin dans la campagne dans les
montagnes ou sont en ce moment les
cueilleuses de t
elle se croyait coupé du monde et puis
pas du tout elles apprennent tout d'un
coup
que ce soir
il y aura un grand spectacle de danse
kathak ali
c'est à dire 12 heures de spectacle sans
interruption au loyer hargne
de danse kathak ali est un poème épique
ma à bata qui est vieux de 3000 ans
c'est un peu l'iliade des indiens
l'histoire d'une guerre entre cousins 5
d'un côté et sans de l'autre qui se
battent pour un royaume et pour une
femme la reine bras ou pas dit
le maquillage se fait selon les règles
d'un art très ancien et très strictes il
s'agit de faire prendre aux danseurs les
aspects des héros et des dieux en leur
appliquant de la patte de gris qui subit
des déformations du visage puis pour
reproduire les matches légendaires on
emploie des couleurs de toutes sortes
cette préparation étrange dure jusqu'à 8
heures il faut respecter les règles de
l'art la pâte de riz doit résister au
mouvement expressif des interprètes afin
de ses danseurs et les yeux rouges et
flamboyant des personnages mythologiques
il n'hésite pas à se mettre dans la
corne est un produit irritant pour
l'instant vous ne le voyez pas mais dans
un petit moment vous allez le voir en ce
moment on s'occupe surtout de la
symétrie les dessins
voilà l'opération vous a indiqué tout à
l'heure et vous allez voir le résultat
en blanc et noir ça se voit tout de même
possible
voyez l'oeil droit par rapport aux
gauches
et les voilà à peu près tous les deux
dans le même être complètement
d'injecter de ça de très lourds voilà
c'est vraiment terrible
mais utile pour avoir l'air eric
le choix est venu ils finissent de
s'apprêter et rajaona lui joue le rôle
d'une femme celui de la reine draoua pas
dit en effet les femmes ne participe pas
au spectacle à cause de la fatigue
rajaona s'est donc mis une jupe se
mettre une perruque et des avantages
en attendant que le public s'installe
ils attendent dans le recueillement le
moment de l'entrée en scène voilà at
il un peu transformé tout de même là
chaque geste exprime un mot que vous et
moi ne comprendrons probablement pas
mais que là bas le public comprend que
les initiés comprennent la reine draw
abadie a eu précédemment des enduits
cessant cousin c'est long et c'est
beaucoup se sont montrés à son égard
d'une incroyable familiarité en présence
de ses cinq maris pas content du tout
elles demandent justice au dieu krishna
et elle est décidée à ne plus se donner
un seul coup de peigne tant qu'elle
n'aura pas obtenu vengeance c'est très
féminin cette réaction le dieu krishna
lui déclare sa haine helmand qui sera
vengé même si le ciel venait à
s'effondrer même si la terre venait à
tomber en poussière même si l'himalaya
revenait à se couper en deux même si la
mère venait à se dessécher en fait tout
un fromage
blanc krishna s'est rendu auprès des
méchants kawara oit pour tenter
d'obtenir la réparation eux ne se sont
pas rendus compte que se guérit
ambassadeurs et des dieux
et comme ils ne se sont pas rendus
compte qu'ils a fait affaire impuissants
ils essaient de l'enchaîner et de lui
lier les poignets et quand il essaie lui
lier les poignets ils en sont
mystérieusement empêcher
cela les surprend évidemment mais ils
finissent par comprendre
qu'ils ont affaire à un dieu
alors il se met à trembler
christmas day gigantesque
et pour ce faire mine monture un
tabouret
et quand ils descendent rassure ce
tabouret il révèlera qu'il
les cahots rawa sont terrorisés de
l'expression effrayante qu'avait pris le
visage du dieu la tentative de paix
ayant échoué ce sera la guerre la
bataille a fait rage
et naturellement trishna parce qu'il est
dieu n'a pas combattu lui même auprès
défend d'avoir mais il a conduit le char
le plus intrépide d'entre eux andy
pourra
ilan chagnaud vous a proposé un voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec le concours de l'office de
tourisme indien à paris et de solange
péters montage michel la touche sont à
nick v dit jean paul tic emploi script
lucette andrieu l'illustration sonore
dominic palladini